vamos a resolver algunos problemas de
suficiencia de información del examen
gmat estos problemas se tratan de lo
siguiente nos hacen una pregunta nos
hacen una pregunta y luego nos dan dos
piezas de información y tenemos que
determinar qué combinación de estas
piezas nos permiten responder la
pregunta y bueno no necesariamente
tenemos que resolver la pregunta nada
más saber si con la información que nos
dan podemos resolverla vale bueno vamos
con el problema número uno nos preguntan
cuánto es el 20% de cierto número el 20%
de cierto número vamos a ponerle x va y
las opciones de información que nos dan
son 110 por ciento del número es 5 o sea
10 por ciento de x es 55 que podemos
reescribir como esto lo podemos
reescribir cómo 0.1 x es igual a 5 y la
otra el otro pedazo de información que
nos dan es que el 40% del doble del
número es 40 40%
de 2x es 40 es 40 y esto lo podemos
escribir como que 40% lo voy a poner
como 0.4 del doble del número de 2x es
igual a 40 a 40
entonces vayamos con la con la primera
información la información del inciso 1
si nos dicen que el 10% de x es 5
entonces 0.1 x es igual a 5 lo que
nosotros queremos determinar es el 20%
de x osea 0.2 x conociendo esto podemos
determinar el valor de 0.2 x pues si
simplemente al multiplicar por 2 esta
igualdad obtenemos que 0.2 x es igual a
10 vale 0.2 x es igual a 10 entonces el
inciso 1 por sí mismo es suficiente para
resolver la pregunta vamos a ver qué
sucede con el inciso 2 en el inciso 2
conociendo que 0.4 por 2x es igual a 40
tenemos que 0 punto
0.8 x es igual a 40 nada más hice la
multiplicación y dividiendo aquí entre 4
ambos lados tenemos una vez más que 0.2
x es igual a 10 vale entonces también el
inciso 2 por sí mismo sirve para
resolver la pregunta que nos hacen le
voy a poner una palomita y en este caso
tenemos que la respuesta es de sale la
respuesta de quiere decir que cada uno
de los enunciados por sí mismo nos ayuda
a resolver la pregunta inicial vamos a
hacer otro vamos al problema número 2 va
problema número 2
dice una mezcla bien revuelta de pan
incluye solo harina y levadura le voy a
poner aquí harina harina y levadura
levadura
y lo que nos piden es determinar la
razón del número de gramos de levadura
al número de gramos de harina entonces
cuál queremos gramos de levadura y
gramos de harina harina muy bien y las
posibilidades que nos dan de información
es 1 número 1 sabemos qué exactamente
9.9 gramos de la harina está en 10%
perdón en 10 gramos de la mezcla
entonces 9.9 gramos de harina está en 10
gramos 10 gramos de mezcla de mezcla con
esto podremos conocer la razón de
levadura a harina pues si si tenemos 9.9
de harina y 10 gramos de mezcla entonces
0.1 gramos de levadura y con esto
tenemos que la razón de levadura harina
es 0.1 a 9.9 9.9 y aquí podríamos
calcular la razón un poco más
explícitamente pero no tenemos que
hacerlo solo tenemos que darnos cuenta
que este inciso nos permite determinar
la razón y el segundo nos dicen nos dice
exactamente 0.3 gramos de levadura 0.3
gramos de levadura están contenidos en
30 gramos de mezcla en 30 gramos de
mezcla va aquí podemos determinar esta
razón pues si una vez más conociendo la
levadura y la mezcla ahora lo que
podemos hacer es determinar la harina si
son 30 de mezcla y 0.3 de levadura
entonces son 29.7 de harina y por lo
tanto la razón de levadura a harina
sería 0.3 0.3 29.7 vale y bueno estas
acá son son las mismas no lo vamos a
hacer pero lo importante es que la
información del 2 es suficiente para
responder la pregunta y por lo tanto una
vez tenemos que la respuesta es de cada
uno de los incisos por separado nos
ayuda a resolver a resolver la pregunta
esto lo estoy aquí lo estoy haciendo
todo de manera improvisada para que veas
bueno para que entendamos un poco que se
siente esto de ver un problema y
resolverlo al instante vale
me equivoco pero eso podría ser
instructivo bueno vamos con el número 3
nos preguntan por el valor absoluto de x
queremos determinar el valor absoluto de
x la primera posibilidad de información
que nos dan es que x es igual a menos el
valor absoluto de x estoy aquí será
suficiente para determinar el valor
absoluto de x pues qué tipo de números
cumplen esto de aquí por ejemplo los
números positivos cumplen digamos el 1
no verdad el 1 no cumple o sea 1
pregunto es igual a valor a menos valor
absoluto de 1 pues no estoy aquí es
falso porque aquí nos diría que uno es
igual a menos 1 entonces el uno no
cumple pero al menos uno el menos 1 x
igual a menos 1 sí porque tenemos que
menos 1 es igual a menos valor absoluto
de menos 1 porque el valor absoluto de
menos 1 es igual a 1 y entonces menos 1
es igual a menos 1 entonces básicamente
lo que nos está diciendo esta igualdad
de aquí es que x es menor o igual que 0
x es menor o igual que 0 para cualquier
negativo o para 0 x es igual a menos el
valor absoluto
vale pero bueno con eso no podemos
determinar o es decir con solo esa
información no podemos determinar el
valor absoluto de xx podría ser menos 5
o menos 10 entonces esta información por
sí misma no nos ayuda a determinar el
valor absoluto de x a lo mejor si
juntamos esa con la del inciso 2 se va a
poder saber el inciso 2 dice x al
cuadrado es igual a 4 x al cuadrado es
igual a 4 muy bien con esta información
que tenemos bueno pues si x al cuadrado
es igual a 4 entonces sabemos que x es
igual a más menos 2 más menos 2 mirad si
juntamos el 1 con el 2 podemos
determinar el valor de x porque aquí nos
dice que x es menor o igual que 0 aquí
que es más menos 2 y entonces x sería
menos 2 entonces juntando los dos
podemos determinar el valor de x pero
nosotros lo que queremos es el valor
absoluto de x vale y observemos que aquí
abajo pues ya tenemos el valor absoluto
porque en cualquiera de los casos el
valor absoluto de más menos 2
igualados y por lo tanto conociendo que
x al cuadrado es igual a 4 podemos saber
que el valor absoluto de x es igual a 2
entonces esta información la del inciso
2 por sí misma si ayuda a resolver la
pregunta inicial y por lo tanto la
respuesta es b b quiere decir el inciso
2 por sí mismo es suficiente pero el 1
no basta vale bueno vamos a hacer un par
de problemas más que todavía tenemos
tiempo vamos con el número 4 el problema
número 4 nos permite dt nos pregunta
cuál nos pide determinar si eres mayor
que 0.27 la pregunta se ve muy fácil
vamos a ver qué opciones tenemos 1 la
opción número 1 es saber que r es mayor
que un cuarto y un cuarto es 0.25
entonces esta de aquí será información
suficiente para determinar si esto es
cierto o no
bueno pues cierre es mayor que ser mayor
que 0.25 r podría ser 0.26 y entonces no
se cumpliría esto o bien erre podría ser
0.3 y entonces si se cumpliría esto
entonces la información del inciso 1 no
es suficiente verdad conociendo esto de
aquí no es suficiente bueno conocer esto
no es suficiente para determinar si el
relé gana 0.27 vamos con el inciso
número 2 el inciso número 2 nos dice r
es igual a 3 decimos r es igual a 3
decimos bueno pues si ya sabemos cuál es
el valor de r claro que vamos a poder
determinar si le gana o no a 0.27 de
hecho tres décimos es igual a 0.3 y este
si le gana 0.27 pero lo importante no es
que si le gané sino que con esta
información si podemos determinar si le
gana o no entonces tenemos que el inciso
2 es suficiente y por lo tanto de nuevo
la respuesta es b vale y finalmente
vamos a hacer el número 5 finalmente en
este vídeo luego le vamos a continuar y
el 5 dice lo siguiente pregunta cuál es
el valor de la suma de una lista de n
enteros impares entonces queremos sumar
n enteros enteros impares
bares impares no nos dicen dónde
empiezan ni cuáles son solo sabemos que
son en enteros impares entonces vamos a
ver qué información adicional nos dan en
los incisos el inciso 1 es n igual a 8 o
sea son ocho números estos de aquí por
supuesto que no es suficiente verdad si
sabemos que son ocho enteros impares
pues eso no nos dice nada acerca de la
suma tenemos que saber quiénes son
entonces esto por sí mismo no responde
la pregunta y el inciso 2 dice el
cuadrado de la cantidad de números es 64
entonces nos dice que n al cuadrado es
igual a 64 con esto tenemos que n es más
menos 8 pero en es una cantidad de
enteros entonces en es igual a 8 es
igual a 8 pero esto es lo mismo que el
inciso 1 verdad en realidad no nos están
dando información adicional y entonces
no podemos resolver la pregunta de
determinar los enteros impares por lo
tanto ni este sirve ni este sirve ni
sabiendo las dos podemos determinar la
respuesta entonces la respuesta sería eh
y él quiere decir ni siquiera ambos
incisos juntos nos permiten responder la
pregunta